thank you so much
okay so moving on as we are talking
about the courses
so here are the different courses that
are there
so this is also what you have access to
so if you are only registered for the
program you will have access to these
links
not everybody may not have access to the
links if you are not registered yet for
the program
so these are the courses that you get
access to from here
and then we have a progress tab so what
does the progress tab
do it shows all of the different
progress you have made across all the
sites so this is the education
site where you have the courses the
forum and your own profile
so right now as we are all starting out
today
we are all going to be starting with
zero and as we move on with this program
we are going to see there are going to
be different numbers so once you
complete
any of these courses you get 500 points
similarly if you run a pipeline you get
50 points so all of those points would
be added
to your progress bar here and we can see
both
individual progresses as well as
the progress for the entire group or the
entire class
right here the second platform
that every registered participant has
access to is the server t by info
platform
so if you have already registered for
the program
you may have received an email from
marketing at prime.bio
with the individual access to this
platform you cannot change the email id
to the server to bioinfo you will have
to use the login id that we have
provided to you
so please make sure that you are able to
log in with the id that is provided and
in case you have any problems
please let us know so that we can make
sure you have
all the access details before the next
session
and the third platform that we have
uh that we will be using during this
program is the code omits logic platform
so the coding platform has courses in r
and python
and we will be uh helping you
learn about applying rn python
to biological data so these are all the
resources that we will be utilizing
during
this one month program and if you have
any questions regarding this you can
either reach out to
africa at pinelot bio or to marketing at
pine.bio anytime
okay so if you are not able to access
lydia so please
send us an email with a screenshot so
that we are able to help it out and we
will do that beyond the session
and now to start with today's session i
would like to invite
elia to take over from now on uh elia
over to you
thank you and welcome everyone to
omix logic metagenomics in nigeria we're
excited to be
starting this program today and we hope
that most of you will be able to benefit
from
the different resources that we provide
as we learn about metagenomics
so let me start by introducing what this
program
will be focused on we hope that most of
you
already have some background in
molecular biology and you will be able
to apply your interest in the microbiome
which is a growing and very interesting
and dynamic field
to learn how to explore microbiome
research projects
and look at different challenges that
are being addressed
using a variety of different techniques
this primarily includes metagenomic
sequencing
which refers to high throughput
generation of short sequencing reads
that could either help us provide a
taxonomic
description of a particular
environmental sample
or study in-depth analysis of
different genes that are being produced
by a community of
microorganisms now the program is
structured in such a way that we will go
from
learning about these different
applications and techniques
to developing an independent research
project so we hope that
even today and as you get started with
your learning
you will start thinking about what kind
of
data what kind of question what kind of
analysis you plan to do
and by the time you complete this
program you will either have a project
proposal
which we will explain how you can
continue to work on
after you complete the basic training
and join our research fellowship program
or even complete some of the analysis in
as short as
one to two months so to get started
let's talk about the history of
metagenomics and why
do we have these novel technologies that
help us characterize the microbiome
so let me give you a little bit of
history about microbiology
where the study of microorganisms led to
the creation of tools
and approaches that are still used today
and continue to uncover the veil
of a world which we do not see but yet
has such
a profound effect on everything around
us including our own health
so here you can see louis pasteur that
lived in the 19th century he's a french
microbiologist a chemist and the pioneer
of the
german theory of disease back when he
was
involved in his research work he was
interested
in seeing the veil from the
microorganisms
being uncovered and really understanding
what is the impact of these germs or
these microbes
on everything around us and so the way
that this
first happened uh it was through the
microscope
in fact the smallest thing
humans could see was about as wide as a
human hair
and when the microscope was first
invented
suddenly we could see a completely new
world
of living things that surrounds
everything that we touch
including our water that we drink the
food that we eat
and even living as communities on our
bodies
and so the first observation of a
bacterium was made around
16-7 around 1673
by the dutch microscopist anton van
leeuwenhoek
thanks to the microscopes that he had
invented and these enlarged
from 50 to about 300 times whatever he
was observing
as the results improved more and more
representatives of the unseen world have
been discovered
and so you can see here an example of
today's microscope
they are tremendously powerful that
allow humans to see
smaller and smaller elements you can see
here in fact
a number of phages that are being that
are attacking
e coli bacteria so this is their
resolution that we are
at today and so as a result
we have a greater ability to see and
understand
the world of these unseen microorganisms
but microbiology itself ended up being
defined
not only by the organisms that it
studies but also by the tools that are
used to study them
these tools are continuing to evolve and
have
already evolved to allow us to study and
categorize
organisms into our understanding
of the living world around us so
technology for bacterial culturing
coupled with a technique to stain
bacteria
first improved our ability to isolate
classify
and determine whether bacteria is the
cause of human disease
and even selecting today these tools
continue
to develop and we can see a greater
resolution
into this world of unseen microbes the
discovery
of cultural media allowed for the
development of microbiology in the 19th
century
bacterial culture is an artificial
medium that allows growth and isolation
of bacteria
and the first to have cultured a
bacterium in a reproducible way
was lewis pasteur in 1860
gram staining is a bacteriological lab
technique
used to differentiate bacterial species
into two large groups
gram-positive and gram-negative based on
the physical properties of their cell
walls
gram stains are performed on body fluid
or biopsy when
infection is suspected gram stains yield
results
which more quickly than culturing and
are especially important when infection
would make an important difference in
the patient's treatment and prognosis
so here we can see an example of what
that looks like
you can see how the bacteria is cultured
and then stained
and this ability to stain could be used
for example on
cerebrospinal fluid for meningitis and
synovial fluid for
septic arthritis so a wide range of
different diseases
could be characterized and accurately
classified
using such techniques the connection
between disease and microorganisms has
been established
back in the 1800s but these studies
provided
not only important information but they
also followed a specific technique that
only could look
at bacteria in isolation but it became
apparent that most microorganisms
actually
live in complex communities many members
of this community are impossible to
culture in isolation
and they live and work together almost
as a single organ which we will learn
about in just a few slides
so that we know today that they
form highly regulated structurally and
functionally organized communities
that are attached to surfaces as
biofilms
with inter-species collaborations as
well as antagonisms
that contribute to their overall
ecological stability
due to the advances in metagenomic
sequencing
and other omics technologies enormous
databases of data
from such communities have led to the
emergence of computational metagenomics
which can help study the 99 of
uncultivatable
organisms in the context of their
natural environment
so this is a brief timeline in the 1600s
we had the first
observations of microscopic organisms by
the 1800s
the connection between microorganisms
and disease has been established
from the late 1800s until present
culture
staining and microscopy were developed
and used in both
research and clinical applications in
the 1980s
until the present we have the emergence
of dna sequencing and the application of
dna sequencing to the study of microbial
communities
in 2008 the human microbiome project was
launched
what kind of an impact this had on the
study of microorganisms
and from the 2010 and to present
bioinformatics and especially
multi-omics integration have really
defined
the world of metagenomics the stability
of these communities
is fascinating as many of us probably
know when trying to battle such common
skin
conditions as eczema acne and dry skin
forming distinct communities these
microorganisms are interconnected
and determined to maintain their
community bacteria within a biofilm
can communicate with each other by
producing detecting
and responding to small diffusible
signal molecules in a process called
quorum sensing
which confirms benefit for host
colonization
biofilm formation defense against
competitors
and adaptation to changes in the
environment quorum sensing activities in
biofilms are also involved in the
virulence and pathogenic potential of
bacteria
and are therefore an important factor in
our ability to understand and control
bacterial infections as they enable
microorganisms and biofilms to become
more tolerant to host defenses
and antimicrobial agents inside each
community
there is a balance of bacteria fungi and
viruses that control species abundance
and activity so the human microbiota
is estimated to be between 10 to the
13th to 10 to the 14th of microbial
cells with around
equal proportion of microbial cells to
human cells
previously it was even thought that that
number is much greater
but today these figures have been
adjusted since 2016.
these numbers are actually derived from
the total bacterial cells
in the human colon which is
approximately 3.8
to the 10 to the 13th of bacteria
the organ the gut harbors the greatest
number of microbes
however each one of these microorganisms
carries important functional properties
in genes that contain genomic
information
about different functions that our body
cannot
do on its own these properties and the
genomic information about microorganisms
have been
of a growing interest to the scientific
community
resulting in well over eighty thousand
publications in the course of the past
few years the majority of the studies
have focused on the intestinal
microbiome
so here you can see how the body is
dominated by specific
types of microorganisms depending on the
organ
and what we are discovering today is
that these microbes
actually communicate with each other and
form
almost a signal a single organ
that functions in a variety of ways
supporting our immune system digestive
system
and controlling the progression of
disease
in fact not so recently in february 2020
a new review article came out on the gut
skin axis
which summarizes the current knowledge
of the interrelationship between
microbial dysbiosis
overall including the gut microbiome and
skin conditions and it describes how
inflammatory
and microbial influences between the gut
and skin for a healthy state and the
dysbiotic state
are designed are a result
of a variety of microbial
changes so this this biotic state is
characterized by an
impaired gut barrier imbalance in the
gut microbiome reduced mucous layer
reduced secretion of different
antibodies
barrier disruption intestinal permeation
into the bloodstream and gut
inflammation
and an impaired skin barrier imbalance
in skin microbiome
reduced human and microbial
antimicrobial peptides
production skin rashes thickening
lesions and skin inflammation
and we can see how gut and skin
dysbiosis are connected
to an immune imbalance so in this study
you can clearly see not only the role of
the skin microbiome but the relationship
between the skin and the gut dysbiosis
in their relationship with the host so
it's really a very close
and interconnected organ now to study
this
there have been a number of microbiome
studies
that have significantly advanced
through major initiatives such as the
metagenomics of the human intestinal
tract
and the subsequent human microbiome
project these are
huge studies that have been made
possible through the advances
in metagenomic sequencing which offers a
cheap alternative
to study microorganisms in their
community without the need of culturing
and with rapid turnover each new project
here represents
vast opportunities and challenges to
determine which microorganisms play key
roles
in the development of certain
environmental conditions needed for
healthy function
of human organs and which can be harmful
to it
specifically we now know of the gut
skin lung and even brain microbiota
that have been characterized and new
associations have been found
from mild conditions such as sensitivity
to different
types of foods to very acute conditions
such as the development of alzheimer's
disease
or even susceptibility to a variety of
infections
over the past decade more than 1.7
billion us dollars
have been spent on human microbiome
research
major projects are underway in the
united states
the european union china canada
ireland south korea and japan this
investment has
confirmed the significance of the
microbiome
to human health and development some 20
of us investment in such research has
gone to two phases
of the human microbiome project which is
creating the research resources needed
to study the human microbiome
one of the main goals of the hmp
launched in 2007
was to create not only a data set but
also a toolbox of computational
techniques
analytical methods and clinical
protocols so that
others can leverage this to understand
the role of the microbiome
so what is known so far about the
microbiome function
is that it plays a significant role in
the differentiation of the human
immune system oh sorry
let me start that over
what is known today about the microbiome
is that it plays a significant role in
the differentiation of the immune system
food digestion and nutrition energy
generation and conservation
metabolic regulation of fat storage
processing of environmental chemicals
maintenance of skin and mucosal barrier
function as well as prevention of
invasion
by pathogens so what we will do in this
program is we will try to identify
how such microbiota could be studied
using next generation sequencing so the
essential steps here
are to understand when we have a
community that can be comprised of
millions of individual microorganisms
how can we use an effective approach to
sequencing the genomic information
about these communities to characterize
the composition
dominance or species richness and the
interaction between the microbiome
and their environment forming specific
conditions
that have have a major contribution to
our
human health as well as the environment
so what is the study of metagenomics
unlike other omics metagenomics does not
study a single organism
but the whole community at once so it
provides us with
a true snapshot of a collection of
organisms
that are specifically in the
process of interacting with their
natural environment
since the genomes are so diverse this is
typically accomplished
by sequencing a specific marker portion
of the genome
instead of all of the genomic material
present
in a given sample so specifically this
is referred to
16s metagenomic sequencing
where the amplification of the ribosomal
rna
from the smaller subunit of the ribosome
that is specific to bacteria can be
amplified using pcr
the 16s gene sequence contains
hypervariable regions
also known as hvrs that provide
species-specific
signature sequences that are useful for
bacterial classification
the benefit of amplification is tied to
the nature of sequencing read length
which can maximize effective output from
very affordable sequencing technologies
so the way that this data is annotated
and analyzed is through computational
processing
which are called metagenomic processing
pipelines
so those are usually utilizing
something that's called operational
taxonomic units or otus
which can be used to classify groups of
closely related
individual reads these all to otus are
formed into groups of closely related
genomic sequences
and represent essentially a cluster that
could be assigned to a phylogenetic
clade
on the taxonomy of the full bacteria
that is
present in a sample the way this is done
is by annotation using different types
of databases these databases include
such
repositories as the silver
green genes ncbi and rdp and so in the
context of this program
we will learn how to utilize these
reference databases to annotate
and understand what kind of composition
are we looking at
in a given microbial sample so
ultimately based on that mapping of
specific regions
amplified from the 16s ribosomal rna
gene and the small subunit of the
bacterial
ribosome otus can be assigned to belong
to a taxonomic class of bacteria
yielding
important information about the
proportionate view of the community
each community can then be studied by
comparing with others
or between similar communities in
different conditions or individuals
such analysis includes an understanding
of how the different types of sequencing
techniques
and analysis of sequencing metadata and
data
could be combined together to really
understand the microbiome
now sequencing is not the only technique
that is used to study the microbiome
another technique is called mass
spectrometry
sequencing allows us to either
understand composition
or study specific isolated genome
and mass spectrometry can tell us what
types of proteins and metabolites are
being produced
to understand what functional
contribution each species might have
or what types of products a community
produces
and how it is metabolized through this
communal
analysis so many questions
about the role of microbiome members and
communities
are being answered using these
technologies and we
we think that the next phase of
microbiome research
lies in the ability to integrate
multi-omics data sets that combine
next generation sequencing mass
spectrometry
structural data as well as phenotypic
information about
overall changes in the community and
their environment
so many questions are going to be
answered through such integration
as you can see represented here through
both annotation
of functional pathways and function as
well as
unsupervised integration between
different types of microbial taxonomy
different products that they produce and
the interactions between them that could
be studied
using sequencing so in this
program the omics logic metagenomics
program
we will go through different examples
with associated training and practice
hands-on practice
on how to use such techniques to be able
to analyze data
and interpret the results of the
analysis in a meaningful way
so to get started with this process i
want to show you
several courses that we have developed
for your asynchronous use
now as a part of this program this will
be supplemented by hands-on activities
that we will do in group sessions
for those of you joining that have not
signed up for the program
you can all try out this introduction to
metagenomics course
to really understand how this works so
let me take you
to the platform and show you what is
inside these courses so this is the link
to our organizational page
again if you're already a part of the
organization you
could be just going to this
organizational page
and i will show you where to find the
associated coursework
so for those of you that are already a
part of the program
you would go right here to the courses
tab
and once you're in the courses tab you
will see
the three courses that we're going to be
covering in this program which includes
an introduction to metagenomics
metagenomics 1 and metagenomics 2.
so these courses have both a theoretical
review of practical assignments
and some data sets that you can go
through to understand
how the microbiome functions so here if
you
go to the course tab you will see
introduction to metagenomics
metagenomics one so you can start
working on those courses for those of
you that are not a part of the program
you can just go right here to courses
and you will find these courses
outside of this group so you want to
look for introduction to metagenomics
which is
a free course that will be available to
all of you
okay so introduction to metagenomics
right here
um let me just paste the link here okay
thank you vipsa you already pasted
introduction to metagenomics
so what is introduction to metagenomics
if you go to the curriculum tab on the
introduction to metagenomics
you will see here that we describe types
of metagenomic sequencing
analysis of 16s amplicon metagenomics
data next generation sequencing
and analysis of ribosomal rna gene
sequences
taxonomic classification as well as the
impact of microbes on the human health
the gut microbiota the brain and
others so this provides a very thorough
overview of a lot of the things that we
covered in today's session
after completing this course you will
receive
a certificate of completion that you
will be able to
leverage in building your resume and
your capabilities
as a bioinformatician
so in other courses that we will
go through in this program you will find
additional
hands-on applications and
important examples that we will go
through so the way these courses
are organized is that you will see
the expectations for each one of the
activities
mapping of conceptual topics because it
can get
quite confusing with a lot of
terminology and a lot of very specific
details that you have to note
that's are being analyzed for which
reason
and how it will introduce you to a
variety of data sets or
projects that you will be able to work
through
and replicate analysis that was
published and described
in high impact research articles and
journals
and then those analysis pipelines will
become an
area for you to practice so that you can
understand the analysis not only by
reading about it but actually doing it
yourself
as a result you will accumulate a number
of points
that will result in levels and badges
that you will get for completing certain
activities
certification through our online
asynchronous
point system as well as in the context
of this group or of this program this
training program
you can also get a certificate of
completion
or a certificate of excellence which
will go to those that actually apply
these methods
to their independent project now in
these online
modules you will see how this key
terminology from a bioinformatics
perspective
is linked to examples of projects where
you can
analyze different types of conditions
that both represent a clinical
condition and some other examples that
are not related to human health
so what are some of these tools that we
will cover
in the in the metagenomics program we
will rely
on the t bioinfo big data analysis
platform
that contains specific analysis
pipelines
or processing tools to manage
and analyze data from next generation
sequencing so here you can see
an example of a popular pipeline called
kinem2
as well as the data 2 pipeline so these
pipelines
could be used to both process the data
eliminate the necessary junk or the
noise from the data
as well as do downstream analysis and
annotation
so to give you an idea of how this works
let's go to server.t bioinfo
so beeps thank you for posting that link
in the chat
please let me know once you are
on this platform so that we could take a
look at some of these
example pipelines and for those of you
that do not have an account yet with us
you have not received the email
we also have a demo account that you can
use that works perfectly fine and just
does not allow you to upload your own
data
so beeps if you could paste the details
and for all the participants please do
let me know once you're on the platform
and you're logged in
all right thank you anita anyone else
you need to go to server
dot t dash bio dot info and
either use account details that you
received by email
or use the demo account with the
username and password
that beeps it posted in the chat box
okay so as you're logging in i'm just
going to give you a little
overview of what you are seeing here
on the screen for areas of analysis
so first of all you will see that there
are multiple sections for sequence
alignment
or sorry for sequence analysis listed
out
for each individual section so each
section represents
a collection of methods required to
process or analyze data
under some of them you will see this
drop down arrow
that represent the demo pipelines that
you can run
now these could be run both with your
account as a part of the program
or a free demo account that you might
have
so we will take a look in just a few
minutes on how to do that
then you see right here your previous
pipelines
so what are the pipelines that you tried
running or completed in the past
you will see right here your profile and
data management
so that you can understand what is your
account
and how you can upgrade and
you also will see here some data mining
utility scripts and machine learning
sections
so we will cover today a number of
examples just to understand how they
work
and what are the inputs and the outputs
and this will include whole genome
analysis
where we can map whole genomes onto a
database of known bacterial genomes
kind 2 is an example that i will show
you
as one of the most probably known
pipelines for analysis
of 16s ribosomal rna sequencing
and the data2 amplicon pipeline and what
are some of the
ways to annotate and interpret this data
using a popular filoseek package
in r okay so let's go to the platform
and the first section that we will go
through is this section for metagenomics
microbiome so if you click
on this arrow you see here
demo metagenomics regular
okay so we can go in there and the first
thing that you will see
is this pop-up that explains what the
pipeline
can look like and what does it do
and what is the meaning behind each one
of the buttons and how to really use
them
okay so you can close this for now
and now we will take a look at one
example
pipeline that simply takes in
some data from the american gut project
which is the largest crowdsource citizen
science project to date
because it involves many people from a
variety of backgrounds that have
contributed
their samples of saliva fecal samples
and others to understand microbial
composition
between a wide range of people after
you've selected this you click on
ok the second thing that we will do is
we will map
onto a reference database using bow tie
to align
so clicking here you will see that we
are mapping on a database called
silva and this is a database of 16s
sequences so here you can click on
ok and then we will create
an abundance table using this annotation
method called pause count
which looks at the count of reads that
map onto a
particular entry into the database so
here you click on
ok and then we want to annotate
the positions in the 16s
rna database to understand abundance
of particular regions and how we can see
those
in our output files so here you can see
how we create a three-step pipeline
and then we click on end and we will see
what are some of the outputs
okay knee is saying that the
website is not responding could you
clarify what is not
uh working for you
so please put it in the chat if you have
some issues with
building this pipeline and we will try
to see
what the issue might be so after you've
done this pipeline you will notice
on top download pipeline output files
so you can click on this and see some of
the results
you will see mapping statistics which is
a process
of annotating how many different reads
mapped onto the reference you will also
see the result
of all of our bow tie mapping
and then you will see a table after
annotation
which is what we want to look at so
let's click on
table after annotation
and see the file that we downloaded so
i'm just going to open this
in excel and show you what's inside
okay how many were able to generate this
file
how many people were able to generate
the result file
okay so if you have what you will see
is that after we have the
id okay so we have here the id
of this particular 16s ribosomal rna
entry and then how it is
organized by taxonomic classification so
here you can see
k p c o
f g s right so these are taxonomic
levels
so based on these taxonomic levels we
can now
organize okay so here you can see the
taxonomic
levels
how we took 16s ribosomal rna sequences
and we can classify them by species
genus family order class phylum or
kingdom and now that we
so kehinde just to kind of remind you
what we did on the platform i'm just
going to show
one more time you go to areas of
analysis
okay again if you're not able to log in
please
use the demo password and
email account that beeps it provided
but here you will find once you're in
a drop down right here
next to metagenomics microbiome you can
also hover over this little eye
to really see what each section does so
under metagenomics microbiome we want to
take this
first demo metagenomics regular
once you're in here you will see a
pop-up which you can close
and in the future if you don't want the
pop-up to come up you can click on this
dashboard
then you click on start you read about
the
input data that we're using which is
from the american gut sample
bow tie to a line where we describe the
database that's used for
mapping pause count which creates an
abundance table and calculates how many
reads are present for a given
entry into the database and then
annotation so that we can annotate
based on taxonomic classification
so after that's done we click on end and
then you should see download pipeline
output files and you can open this
folder like that and now you see a
number of different elements
coming out in this output file folder
so in this folder we managed to download
a file
that looks like this in this file you
will see that the result this is just
one
sample so this sample has
a variety of different positions and we
can sort
by this column
to find the biggest
the most abundant entries into the
database
and so in this way we can start thinking
about
what kinds of bacteria are likely to be
present in the sample
and how do we understand the impact of
such bacteria
on the phenotype which is described
by metadata now in this case
this is a manual pipeline where we take
the downloads
as a table and then we can visualize and
annotate this
using a variety of different annotation
techniques
but let me now show you a different
example where this process
is automated and is specifically
designed
for sequencing of hyper variable regions
so to do that i will go into this last
section called amplicon16s 18s
and i will use this example project for
metagenomics
amplicon gut brain access now it's
called amplicon because we are
amplifying hypervariable regions
and then annotating those hypervariable
regions
again on the same database but only
looking at the regions that are most
representative of this taxonomic
classification so here you can see the
process of
amplicon sequencing with pcr
amplification of variable
regions then you can see what the data
two pipeline consists of which is
primarily the workflow to reduce
noise in our input data so that reads
are denoised merged by pairs
and sequencing and then organized into
clusters
of operational taxonomic units again
those are reduced from
chimers or chimeras assign
taxon by looking at the database
and then we can build a phylogenetic
tree
that can actually help classify
differences between microbiota so here
we use
an r package in filoseq that is going to
be used
for visual visual outputs of
this analysis so once i get to download
pipeline output files
i will see a number of different outputs
including some plots
which are given in a pdf format so for
example here
we see air plots quality profile plots
as well as filoseq plots so we can
download the filoc plots to see what is
the composition between different
samples
so here in filoseq we see
a family level
taxonomy that is distributed between
a number of samples six samples
bkf010203 and then 13 14
and 15. and here we can see
the composition or the species richness
based on this
family taxonomic organization
so then we have to look at how
not only are they individually
represented
but also how are they interrelated a
species that is more divergent
farther away from another species is
more interesting than a species maybe
that is closer together because they
will have a
wider range of functionality and so we
build this
tree of operational taxonomic units
and we can actually study the different
types of diversity
using additional methods like chao and
shannon to understand how
species diversity as well as species
richness
can play a role in a particular
phenotype
okay so now we have a question when
opening txt
file data in excel is it best to save it
as xlsb format or later retrieval
um okay it seems like a question that's
not directly related to what we're
talking about but
yes overall you can probably save it as
an excel file
that way you'll be able to use it later
again easily opening it up in excel
and it will include saving any kind of
figures that you have in your data
that will be saved as well okay so in
this example
we're using a particular data set so to
give you an idea of some of these data
sets
i want to introduce a few different
applications of the microbiome
that we will use in this program
but before i do that i also want to
mention
that we will use some of the methods
that we've seen here
including philosophy and the different
methods that are packaged within this
package
as a way to learn a little bit more
about coding so now to see an example of
how we will leverage
these examples in metagenomics to
understand
coding and popular packages in r and
python
let me take you to another resource that
you will gain access to in the context
of this program
called code omixlogic.com
okay so if you could please put that
on the chat thank you other tyler
so please go with me to code
omixlogic.com
and here you can register for free so
this is a free account that you can
generate
and i will explain in a couple of
minutes how this works and how we will
use this
for generating figures that you see here
on the screen
okay and for anita's question we will
learn about the simpson index
and the shannon index they have a
different ways of calculating
differences between the sample
composition but those specific
differences could be interpreted in
different ways
depending on the type of input data
we have and depending on the question
that we have
okay so let me know once you are logged
in or you have created an account
on code dot omixlogic.com
okay if we could again post that link in
the chat with
https it will be a link
thank you okay so let me know once
you're
on your account on codelogic.com right
let's see
some people started logging in
all right great thank you nida
all right thank you jeremy and lydia
all right great so once you're in the
account you will find
a course called metagenomics
so in this course you will see some of
the examples
of what we will be using to amplify
our understanding of the microbiome
composition
and species richness but also learning
about some very basic functions
in r so in this course you will find
how to generate a
an understanding of what types of
bacteria are present in the sample by
proportion or by abundance
and what are some of the typical
considerations
around leveraging the different outputs
from the pipelines that we already tried
so that your understanding of the
composition is also
considering the abundance of input data
that you have
and the sequencing depth that you are
using
in maybe a different set of samples that
you're using overall
so in this course you will find
different practical tutorials
and let me just show you how those work
okay so once you're here
you can see here a variety of other
courses that you
obviously will get access to as well but
here let's just take a look at this
example
and we'll go right here to number four
and so in this course you can see
that we start with an introduction of a
data set this data set includes a
variety of different cons
conditions and as an example we can use
those that exercise rarely
and those that exercise regularly okay
you will find
in the source data set which is linked
right here
a variety of different metadata that
also
include how often people eat
how often do they drink how uh
what is other kind of lifestyle
conditions that we could link with
microbiome
composition and so once you read about
this
let's uh go to this practice yourself
you cannot open this unless you actually
uh complete the previous steps
uh but here you'll see an example of
what this
how does this actually work okay so
just by simply clicking on this run
button
you will be able to try out the code
that is here and so
obviously you will be able to modify the
code
as you try to arrange this data
in such a way that you can prepare it
for a publication
or present it to your peers comparing
composition by different taxonomic
classes between different conditions
okay so here you will find both
an explanation of the challenge
the code basics as well as
a practice playground where you can try
to modify this code
and produce the types of results
that you would like to use in your
publications
okay so what is going to be included
what we'll do is we will look at a
variety of methods
as well as an understanding of the
typical considerations behind
the statistical analysis as well as the
machine learning
methods that are typically used in
analysis of omics data
as well as specifically for meta genomic
analysis
and we will go through very basic things
to learn how the code works
as well as very specific applications of
the most popular packages
that are used in metagenomic analysis
so let's talk about several examples
that we will use
as data sets to practice
so applications of metagenomics include
analysis of skin conditions food
sensitivity of the gut
autoimmune disorders cancer
antibiotic resistance drug resistance
and even ecological and agrobiological
studies
so we'll take examples from skin and
acne
sensitivity of the gut microbiome and
these different conditions
to play around with the different
methods of analysis and understand
that in the context of different types
of questions and data sets
we should use appropriate methods to
process and
annotate as well as visually present our
data
as i mentioned one of the first projects
that we'll try
is from the american gut project so the
american
gut project is a citizen science project
that has a lot to offer for those
interested in basic and microbial
composition of different types of
samples
from healthy and mildly sick individuals
here we will learn how to create a
report similar to what you see right
here
for an individual that submits their
data
and also how to group people by
different types of composition
of their microbiome to study a condition
however in this example it is very
difficult to
disassociate the impact of microbiome
from other factors that are not related
such as behavior
comorbidities and other unreported
data that we have associated with each
sample
so to study the effect of microbiome
changes
in a unique way we can turn to a
project that we will use that tries to
characterize the relationship between
the
gut and the brain axis by studying
microbiome
and behavioral anxiety so here we will
see
how changes in the gut microbiota
in mice through antibiotic treatments
followed by a gavage of donor stool from
other mice
can help us determine if significant
behavioral changes are induced
and anxiety levels are associated
specifically with microbiome that comes
as a result of
high fat diet or a regular diet for mice
such studies are really important for
our
basic understanding of the role of the
microbiome as well as
in the translation of different types of
probiotic
prebiotic and transplantation
strategies for treatment but we will
also look
how microbiome or the
uh kind of microbial community that
we're studying
can have a variety of other types of
effects and for example we will take
use cases from tuberculosis ebola
and even rhizobacteria which is a
bacteria that grows on the roots of
plants
and how to study such data importantly
we will see that the microbiome is now
considered to be
a major player in many other areas of
biomedical research
for example screening for diagnostic
signatures in precision medicine
and even association with treatment
efficacy
or the therapeutic considerations for
microbiome transplantation
to study such can conditions as
alzheimer's disease so here you can see
an article
where china has already approved
alzheimer's treatment that targets the
microbiome through transplantation
and so importantly we will not only look
at processing
individual types of data but we will
look at how
bioinformatics plays a major role in our
ability to
organize analyze process
and find associations between clinical
and omics data or phenotypic and omics
data
to find important translational insights
about diagnostics therapeutics and even
agrobiology
because today we know that the
microbiome in agriculture
is considered to be an important
component
of production of different crops
resistance and resilience of crops on
harsher conditions that are caused by
the climate change as well as the ideas
about
how to develop novel interventions and
provide better security for food across
around the world so here we can also see
how the applications of microbiome play
an important role in what's going on
right now during the pandemic
many studies have turned to microbiomes
role
in susceptibility and immune response to
covid19
and this is an important part because
the microbiome
is one of the easiest things to sample
in the human body and so this provides
us with a unique
insight into a variety of fields
that have a direct impact on our lives
so in the context of this program we
invite you to
master metagenomics data analysis so
after you complete the program you
should be able to find
analyze and interpret metagenomic data
on your own
and you will be able to gain experience
by doing
this in the context of our interactive
sessions and hopefully if you have the
time to present
your project proposal to also do this to
our community so now i want to open this
up for
any questions that you might have i do
want to mention that
introduction to metagenomics and some of
the coursework
on the code omixlogic.com coding
playground are accessible for free for
those of you that have not yet
registered for those of you that have
registered
you have access to a lot of additional
premium resources that will be provided
in the context of this program
and for those of you that have
registered i want to recommend
that you already start building up your
profile
from uh starting to complete with your
full name
to adding a photo or an avatar
and then starting to accumulate points
so that you can get certification for
the different resources that you
completed
and also gain recognition for the work
that you do
again two types of awards will be
at the end of this program a certificate
of completion or a certificate of
excellence and so um as you think of
your questions
i i will just briefly explain uh what
these two mean
the certificate of completion will be
awarded to anyone
who has over 3 000 points which
equates to about four different courses
and obviously some practice with the
pipelines that are required as a part of
the course
certificate of excellence is awarded to
anyone who has over 10
000 points so 10 000 points
is an easy goal for someone that is
going for
an independent project so if you are
willing to
not only learn about metagenomics but
also
find the data set and try to analyze
this data set
and understand what this data set says
about microbial composition
you are likely to find yourself easily
achieving this 10 000 point goal because
your practice with the coding and with
the different types of
pipelines those will likely to end up
quickly accumulating into 10 000 points
any questions
so if you have any questions you can put
them in the chat box
is there anything else that someone
wanted to add
at a tio or vipsap
okay how much time is required per week
we will have two sessions per week each
session is going to last between 60 and
90 minutes
these sessions are recorded and you can
use the recording to review
the specific things that we have covered
or also to practice on some of the
practical pipelines
for those of you that are interested in
joining this and following this in a
synchronous way
you can actually take a look at how you
can
schedule this on a flexible basis
we have all of the information and i
will just briefly
show the information here
this information is explained on this
page
okay so if you want to learn about the
details you go to the top menu right
here
and you can go to omix logic
metagenomics
okay so in this program i will just take
a look at a couple of events to just
clarify the schedule
now is it required to know python or r
it's not required because we have these
tutorials
that you can follow and learn from the
very very basics
but unlike most programs out there that
focus
a lot on becoming proficient
specifically at coding
we prioritize the logic of analysis so
you know how to critically think about
your data
and use the appropriate tool to be able
to
answer the question at hand specifically
with the type of data that you are
dealing with
so you're more likely to quickly get to
the analysis result
rather than necessarily going through
all of the
training to be able to apply this to
any type of data and this is for
people that do have some background in
life sciences so if you do
already have an understanding of the
microbiome and understanding of cell and
molecular biology
you understand what to look for and how
does this tie in
with the overall concept of metagenomics
this is going to be a huge benefit to
you
so again here you can see uh the paper
the uh um organization page and you can
see the upcoming sessions
so i believe this time is in uh western
africa time
uh
yeah so just to uh address a few
questions here elia
uh for hindi to go first yes uh
the video of this session would both be
posted
in the forum as well as this was a free
session the first session
so this will also be available on the
pine biotech youtube channel as well for
you to review again
if you are already registered for the
program
you will be able to find the video
posted
in the forum like the topics which i had
shown you earlier
it would be posted there and i am
sharing the youtube link right now in
the chat so this is a youtube live
session
so you will also be able to rewatch the
session again via that link
and there is another question which i
would like to address regarding the
access to server to bioinfo so
please make sure whenever you're logging
into server t buyer info
that you are there is no space in
between your username
or password before or after the username
or password as it is case sensitive
so in case there is a blank space it
will treat your password as incorrect
so if you have already received your
details or even if you're utilizing the
demo details just
make sure that you're not putting in
space
so that you avoid the login and mistake
yeah so if you decide to take up a
project and analyze
data sets necessarily
the time period of this program is one
month
but we do understand that projects take
a longer period of time
so what you can do is that you can also
go ahead and join our research
fellowship program
which is primarily dedicated to helping
you develop
a research project of your own under the
guidance of a mentor
so we will talk more about that in the
upcoming sessions
so what we would want to do in this one
month program
is to help you understand get the
training understand the logic
as elia has been explaining to you and
then once you're familiar at least come
up with a research proposal like
figure out what your project would be
so we will have a step-by-step process
that we will take you through
starting with the training with basic
courses getting familiar with the
different pipelines
learning to utilize r and python
for some of the analysis and
visualization
and then thinking of these steps
in terms of a project that you would
want to explore
so if it is not possible for you to do
it in one month because that is
quite a short period of time for doing
your own project
but first getting acquainted with this
system
and then working on a project which we
see that a lot of
our students and participants have been
able to do it
under three months as well so i will be
sharing some examples as well here
in the chat with all of you these are
from participants as well as research
fellows
who are using the account
so the free login is only available for
a limited period of time
and you cannot analyze any kind of data
sets with the free login
you can only run the demo pipelines any
pipeline which is marked with a demo you
can only utilize
that for participants you have
educational access which means that
you have five terabytes of space for
running the pipelines
and you will have access during the
entire length of the program and you
will be
able to analyze data sets from public
domain repositories
like ncbi geo and other such
public domain repositories if you are
looking forward to work with your own
data we do
also offer a research license that
you would have to take up the licensing
for
separately so for demo accounts
you cannot use or upload any files there
is no option to upload files
for educational accounts you can use
again public repositories
and for research accounts you can
utilize a platform
full so these are the different
licensing options which are available
are there any other questions which we
can answer and for any questions you can
either reach out to
the african team at africa pine dot bio
or you can also reach out to me at
marketing and find out bio and i will be
able to help you out with these
questions and also there's a cost to
join the program so the total cost
to join the program
150 usd
and we had like a 33 percent
discount for everybody else who had been
joining till now which made
the cost only 100 usd so if you are
interested please reach out to us via
email
or you can also put in your emails in
the chat box and we will
get back to you so thank you again for
joining today's session
let me just add to that that um we do
have a scholarship program
designed for those that are eager to
learn
and apply what they learn to a research
program a project sorry so
again this is a scholarship opportunity
it is not for everyone it is only for
those that are interested to develop an
independent research project
and work on that project until
completion you can get
up to 50 off in special cases we can
consider
even bigger discounts but it is
specifically designed
for those that are already in some kind
of an academic institution
would like to utilize these tools for a
research project
so you can post the link to the request
of a scholarship thank you
this link will offer you a consideration
about whether that program
is right for you there are certain
requirements
to connect with your faculty and get
recommendation letters etc
but we do encourage you we do have
another week
to complete your registration if this is
something that you're interested in
please follow this process and we will
be our team
either in africa or our core team here
at pine will
reach out to you with any kind of
follow-up questions
thank you everyone it was great to have
you with us
again this video will be posted on our
social media as well as on this
program account and we're going to be
looking forward to seeing you again soon
you